chris spielman the former ohio state
all-american linebacker in great detroit
line chris
good to visit with you hi dad how are
you sir i'm doing okay
at our morning meeting we were wondering
about what is the
atmosphere that feeling around ohio
state football justin fields putting out
this petition
like the last two weeks there um how
would you sum up just the feeling you
get
from uh your callers to your show or
just fans you run into
well i yeah i think it's like everywhere
around the country i think one thing
about football it's a
it's galvanizing especially in the state
of ohio and i think everybody
understands the risk of covet and i
think the
the big concern is and what i think
justin wants and what most of the
parents want
is that they want the right to choose at
the most and at the very
least give us a reason or give them a
reason why
they can't play moving forward i think
that's an obligation of the big ten
but why is it that the acc sec and
big 12 are playing and the big ten is
not
well i think there's a diversity of
opinion on the medical situation and
myocarditis and
you know you have a doctor from the
university of michigan come out who's a
and part of it and said that myocarditis
has been around for years and
i'll give you a perfect example of how
maybe these kids would be a little bit
safer
i'm assuming you talked about cameron
smith the linebacker of the minnesota
vikings
who had covid they went got his heart
checked
and they found out that he needed a
life-saving surgery quite frankly
and that was all because he got his
heart checked and it had nothing to do
with
covet or covet symptoms but i think if
you go about that protocol what's going
to happen is maybe you'll be able to
find some heart issues that some kids
may have
that otherwise would went undiagnosed
what would you ask
the commissioner of the big ten uh
why i mean i look i have a daughter dan
that's a basketball player bg
at bowling green for those of you those
that not from ohio
that don't know where bg is and
you know so i understand the player's
concern so if they would cancel
my cancel my daughter season the one
question okay give me the reason
why and why did it change over a
five-day period
and we at least at the very least need
to know why
and uh then i also think from my
perspective
coming from a parent's point of view as
a player it's obvious i'd want to play
but coming from a parent
if you're going to make this decision
then tell me why because all of a sudden
it's going to affect a lot of kids
futures because you think about it
players that go into this that have
dreams and everybody that goes to ohio
state thinks they're an nfl player i
think you would agree with that
so you're eliminating the undraftable
kid
to becoming draftable you're eliminating
the seventh round kid to become a third
round kid or
in joe burrow's case the fifth round kid
become a first round kid
that's just a small part of it but
that's a part of it
yeah i'm trying to figure this out and
that's why we're going to have the
ncia's chief medical officer on
because i don't think he has any
jurisdiction over the sec acc
and the big 12 to play football and i
have said this to
a couple of coaches we've had on why
can't i get
the medical people with the sec acc and
big 12 on with the medical people the
big ten
and pac-12 and let's just talk do it a
zoom call
let us let us you know listen in and
understand the transparency if there is
transparency with this so we understand
what
one conference is doing and what another
conference is not doing
so that would require strong leadership
in my opinion
no i'm not i'm not trying to be a smart
aleck here i'm just saying
somebody has to stand up and take the
lead can the kids get covet playing
football
absolutely 100 yes can the kids get
covered not playing football
absolutely 100 yes and so
the question i would ask if i were a
parent or
again if i were leading i would say we
are opening up the schools ohio state's
going to have
40 000 students check in do they have to
sign a waiver
you know i mean what are we doing here
somebody's got to get together
they have to assume control and come to
a consensus
and until you do that you're going to
have everybody playing by their own
separate rules
he's chris spielman the nfl analyst with
fox sports former uh
nfl great and certainly played at ohio
state what's your favorite
nfl memory that you'll tell your
grandkids
um well probably i it kind of go
goes together the first preseason game i
played was in cleveland
and daryl rogers long forgotten name but
a very good man was the head coach of
alliance who drafted me
came in the team meeting afterward and
he said to me
where's spielman this is how he started
meeting that was the absolute worst
performance i've ever seen out of a life
i can't believe we drafted you in the
second round you look like a blind dog
in a butcher shop you have no idea what
you're doing you're running around crazy
so that whole week my coach came up to
me and said we're starting in the second
preseason game
in the second preseason game before the
game i remember saying to myself
this is your destiny it's now or never
either you're going to be a player or
you're not i went out and played well
and
and the kind of the rest is history so i
know that's not a very exciting moment
but for me
it was life-changing and it set my
destiny and my future from then on
moving forward
and you also got to play with barry
sanders right
yeah that i'm sure can i give you a
quick story about barry
absolutely first first uh third day
and that barry reported to camp he was
late
um he ran the ball we had a full pads
practice
i went up and hit barry sanders and you
remember wayne dan used to drive around
in that golf cart and smoked a cigar
well you know
wayne's from canton i don't know if you
knew that or not but i'm from canton
maslin area and wayne comes up with a
cigar in his golf cart
and he comes up say chris i played
against your dad i've known your dad for
30 years
i love you i love you like a son but i
gotta tell you
if you hit barry again i'm gonna put
your ass on the bus back to canton in no
time
message received coach hands off barry i
got it
yeah normally it's hands off the
quarterback but this
was not that you could really put your
hands on barry
like i've never seen somebody make so
many people miss
of all the running back maybe you played
against somebody who i did i did play
against him in buffalo
yeah and uh the only reason i got a good
shot on him but the only reason why
was that he never saw me now if he saw
you yeah
he had no chance i'm serious so it's
just amazing what he was able to do in
my mind of course i'm biased but
i think a lot of people's mind the best
ever i saw
did you put up your uh big ten
championship ring for auction
i put two of them up for auction for
covered relief so bruce julie and i do a
podcast together
and i thought you know god has given me
a position
to do something and so my goal was the
number
40 is is biblical in a way and so i
raised 40
000 to give away a thousand dollars for
40 weeks
and that will end in january so we draw
four names out of the hat
every week we give 250 away to four
different people who are nominated
and so it's just my way of doing so i've
been given a platform
and whether it's for breast cancer
research in honor of my late wife or
covet relief or we just had a big
fundraiser for als where we raised fifty
thousand dollars for my teammate william
white at ohio state in detroit
uh i have an obligation to give back and
uh
it's something that uh i take seriously
and
you know it's the lesson that i try to
teach my family is what you give will
grow and what you keep you lose
so i try to give it away as much as i
can
and i i i know you missed stephanie but
you know she was such a
strong woman yeah i i got remarried to a
youngstown girl
and it's interesting i don't
i mean if i can say this or not but you
know it's interesting that i thought i
would never get remarried
and it's interesting about the concept
of grace that
the only way i could love another woman
if it would be that was totally
different
so i married a youngstown girl i can't
get off the northeast ohio chicks
they're just tough as hell dad i mean
but
but i i i was able to love again but
it's totally different i don't know if
that makes sense but
widowers in my position who have
remarried understand exactly what i'm
talking about
it's great to talk to you how are the uh
buys and tries there
how are you uh i'm in the weight room
now man
you remember uh i got my jersey of eric
andelsack remember him he's
my teammate that was killed tragically
by a a drunk driver so that's about the
one of the two jerseys i have hanging up
in this weight room and uh it's just to
honor him so
uh it's going great man i can't i can't
complain i i try to work out and
exercise and eat healthy and
control as much as my destiny as i can
tell bruce we said hello great to talk
to you again chris thank you brother
all right god bless you thank you that's
chris spielman